This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. It's one of the most iconic movie soundtracks of all time. In 1975, a young Steven Spielberg scared the living daylights out of millions of people with jaws. A great white shark terrorizes in New England beach town. As one victim becomes two and then three and then four, people respond first with denial, then fear, and finally outright hysteria. After watching the movie, I remember being scared to even stick my toe in the ocean.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这是有史以来最具标志性的电影原声之一。1975年，年轻的史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格凭借《大白鲨》吓坏了数百万观众。一条大白鲨在新英格兰的一个海滩小镇制造了恐怖。随着受害者从一个变成两个，然后三个，再到四个，人们的反应先是拒绝承认，然后是恐惧，最后是彻底的歇斯底里。看完这部电影后，我记得自己甚至害怕把脚趾伸进海洋。
And even today, when I go to the beach, I can't help but peer out at the water and ask myself, is that a dorsophon? This week on Hidden Brain, the disconnect between our fears and the real dangers we face in our daily lives. As the world grapples with a devastating pandemic, we consider how our minds assess risk, what makes us focus on some threats and not on others, and how can we use this knowledge to prepare for the future? Paul Slovik is a psychologist at the University of Oregon. For decades, he has studied how people think about risk and the mismatch between the intuitive
甚至在今天，当我去海滩时，我还是忍不住眺望水面，问自己，那是背鳍吗？本周的《隐藏的大脑》，探讨我们的恐惧与我们在日常生活中面临的真实危险之间的脱节。正当世界与一场毁灭性的全球大流行病做斗争时，我们思考我们的大脑是如何评估风险的，是什么让我们关注某些威胁而不是其他威胁，以及我们如何利用这些知识来为未来做准备？保罗·斯洛维克是俄勒冈大学的心理学家。几十年来，他一直在研究人们如何思考风险，以及我们对风险的直观感受与我们科学分析风险的方式之间的不匹配。保罗·斯洛维克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，香卡。很高兴来到这里。保罗，多年来，电影《大白鲨》让人们害怕去海滩。看完电影后，你有没有三思而后行，考虑过在海里游泳？我笑了，因为我不会游泳。我是20世纪40年代芝加哥的一个孩子，当时正处于小儿麻痹症流行期间。我们不被允许去游泳，因为人们认为这会使我们容易感染小儿麻痹症，所以我从未学会很好地游泳。所以我远离水，因此我不担心鲨鱼。
feelings we have about risk and the way we analyze risk scientifically. Paul Slovik, welcome to Hidden Bray. Thank you, Shankar. Glad to be here. For years, Paul, the movie Jaws made people afraid of going to the beach. Did you ever think twice about swimming in the ocean after watching the movie? I laughed because I'm not a swimmer. I was a child in Chicago in the 1940s during the polio epidemic. We weren't allowed to go swimming because it thought it would made us susceptible to polio, so I never learned to swim very well. So I stay away from water, so I don't worry about sharks.
学会了很好地游泳，所以我远离水。所以我也不担心鲨鱼，但我很清楚，许多住在海洋附近的人对此相当担心。因此，当然，人们对鲨鱼的恐惧程度与我们真正应该感到的恐惧程度之间存在着严重的不匹配。鲨鱼每年大概杀死五到六人，而且这是全世界范围内。与此同时，人类每年杀死大约一亿头鲨鱼。如果要说的话，应该是鲨鱼拍恐怖片来吓唬我们才对。没错。
learned to swim very well, so I stay away from water. So I don't worry about sharks, but I was clear that many people who lived near oceans were quite worried about it. So there's a serious mismatch, of course, between how afraid people are of sharks and how afraid we ought to be. Sharks kill maybe five or six people a year, and that's worldwide. And meanwhile, humans kill about 100 million sharks a year. If anything, it's the sharks who should be making horror movies about us. Right.
这部电影在我们的脑海中创造了生动的画面，带来了一种体验感。因此，与统计数据相比，这更强烈地引发了人们对鲨鱼袭击的风险感。是的，当然，不仅鲨鱼袭击是这样，多年来好莱坞告诉我们的所有事情都是如此。你知道，从蛇到连环杀手，我们脑海中的风险大大夸大了这些事情对我们产生影响的实际风险。
The movie created vivid images in our mind, in a sense of experience. And so that creates a sense of risk of shark attacks much more powerfully than the statistics do. Yeah. And of course, this is true, not just of shark attacks, it's true of all the manner of things that Hollywood has told us about over the years. You know, everything from snakes to serial killers, the risks in our minds vastly exaggerate the actual risks of those things affecting us.
是的，我们发现我们的风险意识受到我们直接经验的影响，以及我们通过电影或新闻媒体等媒体获得的间接经验的影响，这对我们有着非常强大的影响力。因此，当人们思考风险时，我认为许多人自动假定风险是你正在分析的东西。你会分析某种情况下有什么风险，
Yes, what we find is that our sense of risk is influenced by the direct experiences we have and the indirect experiences we have through media, such as film or the news media, that's very powerful in influencing us. So when people think about risk, I think many people automatically assume that risk is something that you're analyzing. You analyze what the risks are in a situation,
但你和许多其他人认为，大多数时候，当人们在思考风险时，他们实际上并没有使用分析来评估风险。你刚才提到人们使用的是自己的感觉。你能谈谈这个观点吗：对许多人来说，我们的情绪，我们的情感，与我们对风险的感知紧密相连。我们最初认为人们是在分析风险，在他们的脑海中对发生坏事的概率进行某种形式的计算，
but you and many others argue that most of the time when people are thinking about risks, they're actually not using analysis to evaluate risks. You mentioned a second ago that people use their feelings. Can you talk about this idea that for many people, our emotions, our affect is closely tied up in our perceptions of risk. We originally thought that people were analyzing risk, doing some form of calculating in their minds about what the probability of something bad happening
以及这会有多严重，甚至可能将结果的严重程度乘以概率，以得出某种对伤害的预期。当我们开始研究这一点时，我们发现基本上我们可以做这些计算，但依靠我们的感觉肯定更容易。这很容易做到，感觉很自然，而且通常能让我们达到目的，除了它失效的时候。而且通常能让我们达到目的，除了它失效的时候。
would be and how serious that would be and perhaps even multiplying the severity of the outcome by the probability to get some sort of expectation of harm. And as we started to study this, we found out that basically we can do those calculations, but it's certainly easier to rely on our feelings. It's easy to do, it feels natural, and it usually gets us where we want, except when it fails. and it usually gets us where we want, except when it fails.
我们的感觉有时会欺骗我们，这正是我的同事们和我所研究的：我们什么时候可以信任我们的感觉，什么时候我们应该停下来，进行更仔细、更反思性的思考，并依靠数据、论证和科学来做出决定？依靠数据、论证和科学来做出决定。我记得有一次在哥斯达黎加，我想是的，我们要去玩滑索，你知道你被系在一根距离地面大约200英尺的钢丝上。
And there are certain ways that our feelings deceive us, and that's what my colleagues and I study is, when can we trust our feelings, and when should we stop and think more carefully and reflectively and look to data and argument and science to make a decision? to data and argument and science to make a decision. I was remembering one time I was in Costa Rica, I believe, and we were going a zip lining and you know you're attached to this wire
我记得就在我即将跨出这个边缘的那一刻，我被一种荒谬感紧紧抓住，我觉得我在做的事情绝对是疯了。当然，在那个时候，我并没有计算绳索断裂的风险是什么，安全带松脱的几率是多少。这完全是我胃里的感觉
that's about 200 feet above the earth. And I remember the moment at which I was about to step off this ledge, I was just gripped with this sense of lunacy that what I was doing was absolutely insane. And at that point, of course, I was not calculating what are the risks that the rope will break, what are the odds that the harness will come loose. It was entirely what I felt in my stomach
本质上告诉我，这是一项极具风险的活动。是的，事情就是这样。在我开始理解风险和感觉的概念后，我回顾了自己的经历，并意识到一个非常戏剧性的时刻，当时我的感觉在非常强烈地引导着我。那是我在芝加哥附近一条繁忙的高速公路上开车时汽油用光了的一次经历。我把车停在路边，然后我想，好吧，最好去找个加油站，买个油桶，把它装满，然后
that essentially told me this is an extremely risky activity. Yes, that's the way it goes. After I had come to appreciate the concept of risk and feelings, I looked back in my own experience and recognized a very dramatic moment when my feelings were guiding me very powerfully. And that was a time when I was driving on a busy freeway near Chicago and ran out of gas. I pulled the car off to the side of the road and then I thought, well, okay, I'd better go find a gas station and get a gas can and fill it and
回来。但为了做到这一点，我意识到我必须穿过这条高速公路。于是我开始穿过高速公路，每当我把一只脚踏上路面，看着以每小时60英里速度驶来的汽车以及它们离得有多远时。当我把脚放下时，我就会被这种恐惧紧紧抓住，然后我会退缩回来，希望能找到一个更大的空隙，我可以迈出步子而不会感到害怕。在很多方面，这完全说得通。我的意思是，当你在讲这个故事时，我也被一种恐惧感抓住了，想到你，保罗，竟然敢在芝加哥横跨六车道的车流中迈出脚步。
come back. But to do that, I realized I have to cross this freeway. And so I started to cross the freeway and I would take a step onto the pavement and be looking at the cars approaching at 60 miles an hour and how far away. And as I put my foot down, I would be gripped by this fear and I would retreat back and wait in hopes that I would find a bigger gap where I could step out and wouldn't be afraid. And in many ways this makes total sense. I mean, as you're telling the story, I'm gripped by a sense of fear of thinking of you, Paul's, stepping out across six lanes of traffic in Chicago.
没错。在某种程度上，这个系统在大部分时间里运作得非常好。这是值得一提的。我的意思是，事实上，你不需要计算移动汽车的速度以及它们到达你身边需要多少时间，然后把所有这些写在一张纸上，你只是被一种“这极其不安全”的感觉所攫取，然后你退了回来——那种恐惧，那种风险感知，在大部分时间里都对我们很有帮助，不是吗？完全正确，这就是为什么我们这样做并继续这样做，因为大多数时候，我们的感觉对我们是有用的。如果我们的感觉已经通过经验得到了适当的调节。
Right. And at a certain level, the system works very well much of the time. It's what it's worth saying. I mean, the fact that you didn't have to calculate the speed of the moving cars and how much time they would get to get to you and write all that down on a sheet of paper, you just were gripped by a sense that this is extremely unsafe and you step back, that kind of fear, that kind of risk perception, holds us in good stead much of the time, does it not? Exactly, that's why we do it and we keep doing it is because most of the time, on our feelings works for us. If our feelings have been conditioned properly by experience.
所以它是极具适应性的，除了在它出错的时候，就像有时会发生的那样。所以我想谈谈这种关于风险的直觉有时会与我们对风险的分析性思考发生冲突的一些时刻和方式。有一些实验非常完美地梳理出了这种张力。我想从克里斯托弗·C（Christopher C.）的一项研究实验开始。志愿者被告知，他们要么有很低的概率损失20美元，要么有很高的概率
So it's very adaptive, except when it goes wrong, as it sometimes does. So I want to talk about some of the times and ways in which this intuitive sense of risk that we have runs up against our analytical approach to thinking about risk. And there have been a number of experiments that have teased out this tension very beautifully. I want to start with an experiment that the research of Christopher C. once ran. Volunteers were told they either had a low probability of losing $20 or a high probability
损失20美元。他们面临损失20美元的高概率。然后他们被问及为了避免这种风险他们愿意支付多少钱。结果完全如你所料。人们愿意支付大约一美元来避免损失20美元的低概率风险。但如果面临损失20美元的高概率风险，他们愿意支付大约18美元。所以非常理性。然后研究人员以一种相当残酷的方式调整了这个实验。保罗，你还记得他们做了什么吗？是的，他们说如果坏事发生，你将会受到一次
of losing $20. They high probability of losing $20. They were then asked how much they would be willing to pay to avoid this risk. And the results were exactly what you'd expect. People were willing to pay about a dollar to avoid the low probability risk of losing $20. But we're willing to pay about $18 if they faced a high probability risk of losing the $20. So very rational. Then the researchers tweaked the experiment in a rather cruel fashion. Do you remember what they did Paul? Yes, they said that if the bad event happens, you're going to get a
强烈的电击。不是那种真正危险的电击，但会非常令人不快。一组被告知有99%的几率遭到电击。第二组则有大约1%的几率遭到电击。结果怎么样？人们是如何反应的？当他们面对损失20块钱的低概率和高概率风险时，他们的反应是否同样理性？嗯，面对1%电击几率的那组人，愿意支付几乎和99%那组人一样多的钱来避免这种电击。这种反应对电击的概率并不敏感。那么这里实际发生的情况是什么呢？为什么当人们面临1%的电击风险时，在他们的脑海里，感觉就像你在讨论99%的
strong electric shock. Not, you know, one that is truly dangerous, but it's going to be very unpleasant. One group was told it was 99% chance of the shock. The other second group in like a 1% chance of the shock. And what happened? How did people react? Did they react in the same rational way when they confronted the low probability and high probability risk of losing 20 bucks? Well, the group that faced a 1% chance of shock, we're willing to pay almost as much as the 99% group to avoid that shock. The reaction was not sensitive to the probability of the shock. So what is actually going on here? Why is it that when people are facing a 1% risk of an electric shock, in their minds, it feels as if you're talking about a 99% risk of getting
电击风险一样？为什么当谈到电击时与谈到损失20块钱相比会有所不同？嗯，损失20块钱，我们可以说，相对来说是无情感色彩的。我的意思是，当然，我们不想损失20美元，但它不会像潜在的电击那样引发强烈的情绪反应。所以当你想到要遭受电击时，这种想法会在你心中产生一种焦虑感。而这种焦虑感，无论你是以1%的几率还是99%的几率来思考它，都是一样的感觉，
an electric shock? Why is it different% risk of getting an electric shock. Why is it different when it comes to the electric shock compared to when it comes to losing 20 bucks? Well, the loss of 20 bucks, we would say, is relatively affect-free. I mean, sure, we don't want to lose 20 dollars, but it's not as strongly an emotional reaction as much as the potential shock was. So when you think about getting a shock, that thought creates a feeling in you of anxiety. And that feeling of anxiety is the same feeling if you're thinking about it with a 1% or a chance or 99%,
你仍然在想着电击。因此，大脑并不会根据概率来调节或乘以这种由电击意象带来的感觉——也就是说，我们的所谓“感觉系统”不会做乘法。当我阅读这个实验时，我有点试着把自己放在志愿者的立场上，当然，当我试图这样做的那一刻，我脑海中浮现的事情是我最后一次经历电击的经历，正如你所指出的，在那个时候让我把这种感觉乘以1%或99%是不太可能的，因为我的大脑现在处于情感和情绪的领域，而不是计算的领域。没错，我们可以进行那种乘法的一种方式是，如果我们把那1%推向“它不会发生，它仍然是零”的领域，我们就可以通过这种方式关闭这种感觉。但这是一种相当粗糙的计算方式。一旦你越过零，达到了你认为实际上可能会发生的概率，那么根据该概率来调节感觉就非常困难了。当然，在现实世界中，大多数事情都不是零概率或100%。它们通常介于两者之间。当风险产生恐惧或畏惧感时，
you're still thinking about the shock. And therefore therefore the mind does not modulate or multiply that feeling from the shock image by its probability that is our quote, feeling system doesn't do multiplication. When I read the experiment, I sort of tried to put myself in the shoes of the volunteers and of course the moment I try to do that, the thing that my mind went to was the last time I experienced an electric shock and as you point out at that point asking me to multiply that feeling by either 1% or 99%, that's not really possible to do because my brain now is in the realm of affect and emotion as opposed to calculation. That's right, one way we can do that multiplication and that is if we sort of
我们进行分析思考的能力就会受损。保罗说，这就是为什么我们担心遭到鲨鱼袭击，而不是担心在去海滩的路上发生车祸这种可能性大得多的前景。同样的情况也时常发生：有时我们的大脑会被恐惧压得喘不过气来，以至于无法准确处理任何额外的恐惧。这个想法建立在心理学的一个称为“心理物理学”的领域之上。心理学中一些最早的实验是观察我们如何
push that 1% down to the realm of it's not going to happen, it's still at zero, we can then turn off the feeling that way. But that's a rather crude kind of a calculation there. Once you get above zero to a probability that you think might actually happen, then it's very difficult to modulate the feeling by that probability. Of course, in the real world, most things are not zero probability or 100%. They're usually somewhere in between. When risks produce a feeling of fear or dread,
感知亮度或声音的响度。他们发现的是，在非常低的亮度水平或非常低的响度水平下，我们非常敏感。在一个安静的房间里，你能听到耳语。但随后，随着声音的响度或光的亮度增加，需要更大的差异才能让我们注意到。正如我们所看到的，我们对风险的感觉很少由数据决定，或者不仅仅由数据决定。我们的感觉是由故事、图像以及我们群体的共识塑造的。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们对风险的感知如何塑造我们对凶杀案、气候变化和全球大流行的看法。
our capacity to think analytically is impaired. Paul says this is why we worry about getting attacked by sharks rather than the far more likely prospect of getting in a car crash on the way to the beach. It's also the case that sometimes our brains get so overwhelmed with fear that they can't accurately process any additional fear. This idea builds on an area of psychology called psychophysics. Some of the very earliest experiments in psychology were looking at how we
你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。几十年来，心理学家一直在探讨人们是如何得出某事是有风险的还是没有风险的结论的。他们已经确定了许多塑造我们风险感知的因素。这些研究发现，我们分析风险的方式与我们对风险的感觉之间存在显著的差距。这两者并不总是匹配的。心理学家保罗·斯洛维克探讨了
perceived brightness or the loudness of a sound. And what they found was that we're very sensitive at very low levels of brightness or very low levels of loudness. It's in a quiet room you can hear a whisper. But then as the loudness of the sound or the brightness of the light increased, it took more of a difference to make us notice. As we've seen, our feelings about risk are rarely shaped by data or by the data alone. Our feelings are shaped by stories, by images, and by the consensus of our groups. When we come back, we look at how our perceptions of risk, shape how we think about homicide, climate change, and global pandemics.
当这两种思维方式产生不同的答案时，现实生活中会发生什么。保罗，如果你问美国人有多少人死于凶杀和恐怖主义，他们很可能会高估这种风险。如果你问多少人死于心脏病和糖尿病，我们往往会低估这种风险。保罗，你能解释一下有时被称为“易得性启发式”的心理捷径是如何塑造这些看法的吗？是的，“易得性启发式”指的是这样一种机制：我们通过某件事在脑海中想象出来的容易程度，或者在过去记忆中浮现出来的容易程度，来判断其发生的频率或概率。因此，我们利用可想象性和可记忆性作为判断概率和频率的捷径。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Over several decades, psychologists have explored how people arrive at their conclusions that something is risky or that something is not risky. They have identified a number of factors that shape our perceptions of risk. These studies have found a significant gap between the way we analyze risks and the way we feel about risks. The two don't always match. Psychologist Paul Slovik has explored what
同样，在一个非常日常的水平上，这个系统完全说得通。我的意思是，更容易浮现在脑海中的事情，实际上可能正是对我们所处环境更重要的事。因此，这种粗略的经验法则、捷径、启发法，并不总是坏事。事实上，在我们生活的大部分时间里，这可能非常有用。是的，因为正如你所说，可想象性和可记忆性与频率有关，但并非总是如此。有些事情是非常戏剧性的事件。它很容易被记住或想象会发生，因为我们在电影或其他地方看到过。这会让我们产生一种感觉，即这件事很频繁或很有可能发生，而实际上从统计学上讲它极不可能发生。特别是如果该事件不仅
happens in real life when these two ways of thinking produce different answers. Paul, if you ask Americans how many people are killed by homicide and by terrorism, they are likely to overestimate the risk. If you ask how many people die from heart disease and diabetes, we tend to underestimate the risk. Can you explain how a mental shortcut that sometimes call the availability heuristic might shape these perceptions, Paul? Yes, the availability heuristic refers to the mechanism whereby we judge the frequency or the probability of something by how easy it is to imagine it happening or to remember it happening in the past. So we use imaginability and memorability as a shortcut way of judging probability and frequency.
戏剧性（你知道，所以它留在我们的记忆中），而且如果它带有情感或情绪，这种感觉就会放大可记忆性的效果，使它看起来更有可能发生。保罗，研究人员塔莉·沙里特（Tally Sharrit）曾进行过一项研究，她向人们提出了许多关于潜在负面生活事件的问题。她询问了他们个人认识的人将要死亡的可能性，或者他们自己将患上重病的可能性，或者他们将严重出丑的可能性。她发现，人们普遍低估了坏事发生在自己身上的可能性，
And again, at a very everyday level, this system makes perfect sense. I mean, things that do come more readily to mind might actually be things that are more important to the context that we find ourselves in. And so this rough rule of thumb, this shortcut, this heuristic, it's not always a bad thing. In fact, for much of our lives, this might be very useful. Yes, because, as you say, imaginability and memorability are related to frequency, but not always. It's something that's a very dramatic event. It's easy to remember or imagine happening because we've seen it in a movie or something. Will it us to have a sense that this thing is frequent or likely when in fact statistically it's very unlikely. And particularly if the event is not only
与坏事发生在其他人身上的可能性相比。乐观主义和乐观偏差是否塑造了我们直面危险的能力？是的，它引导我们对处理情况的能力抱有比实际情况更多的信心。我想即使沙里特教授也会说，在许多情况下，乐观偏差是具有适应性的。它引导我们采取行动，否则我们在某些情况下可能只会相当被动。因此，它引导我们去冒那些通常是有益的风险。
dramatic, you know, so that sticks in our memory, but if it carries affect or emotion, that feeling then amplifies the effects of memorability and makes it seem even more likely. Paul, the researcher Tally Sharrit once conducted a study where she asked people a number of questions about potential negative life events. She asked them about the likelihood that someone they knew personally was going to die, or that they would suffer a serious illness, or that they would seriously embarrass themselves. And she found that people generally underestimated the likelihood of bad things happening to them
所以这是一件好事。但它也可能导致我们在处理某些确实非常危险且超出我们能力范围的特定类型情况时，对自己处理这些情况的能力过于自信。而且我们经常觉得自己在控制某些事件的事实，我们在吸烟方面也很大程度上看到了乐观偏差，人们承认吸烟总体对健康无益，但他们觉得他们可以以尽量减少这些风险的方式吸烟。这就是最迷人的地方，因为乐观偏差不仅仅是你
compared to the likelihood of the bad thing happening to other people. Does optimism and the optimism bias shape our ability to look danger in the eye? Yes, it leads us to have more confidence in being able to cope with the situation and perhaps is warranted. And I think even Professor Shiroit would say in many cases, the optimism bias is adaptive. It leads us to take action, where otherwise we might just be rather passive in situations. So it leads us to take chances that are often beneficial.
低估了总体的风险，你是低估了你自己的风险。你认为其他人同样容易在公路车祸中丧生或因吸烟而患癌症，你只是觉得不知为何自己很特别。是的，觉得你不会抽烟很长时间，或者你会抽危害较小的香烟，或者每天少抽几根烟，或者所有这些事情都会让你以你认为别人不会做的方式来控制风险。
So it's a good thing. But it can also lead us to be very overconfident in our ability to handle certain types of situations that are really quite dangerous and are beyond our capability. And the fact that we feel often that we're in control of some of these events, we saw also optimism bias greatly with regard to cigarette smoking, where people recognize that smoking is in general not good for your health, but they felt that they could smoke in ways that minimize those risks. That's what's so fascinating about this, because the optimism bias is not just that you're
以你认为别人不会做的方式来控制风险。谈谈累积风险的概念。你知道，如果我在某次开车时不系安全带，我在车祸中丧生的概率可能非常低。但如果我多年不系安全带，累积的风险可能会相当大。我们在脑海中追踪这些随着时间推移逐渐累积的风险的能力有多好？我认为我们并没有真正在进行累积评估。我想，当安全带首次引入时，这一点非常明显。
underestimating risks in general, you're underestimating the risks for yourself. You think that other people are just as vulnerable to getting killed in a highway crash or getting cancer from smoking, you just think that somehow you're special. Yes, that you're not gonna smoke very long or that you're gonna smoke cigarettes that are less harmful or fewer cigarettes per day or all of these things will enable you to control the risk in ways
当时有一些非常有影响力的广告活动，试图激励人们使用它们。只有大约10%或15%的司机佩戴安全带，这是一个非常低的比例。所以他们开展了这些活动，让人们为了安全系好安全带。当你坐在美国，向世界展示你的关怀。今天就系上安全带。向世界展示你的关怀。今天就系上安全带。欢迎你们。而它们并没有起作用。这在思考方式上几乎没有什么影响。假设我们一生中进行了5万次出行，而这些单次出行实际上相当安全，所以人们并没有因为系安全带而得到奖励。那有点不舒服。并且如果他们没有
that you don't think other people are doing. and able you to control the risk in ways that you don't think other people are doing. Talk for a moment about the idea of cumulative risks. You know, I might have a very low probability of getting killed in a car crash if I don't wear a seatbelt on one drive. But if I don't wear a seatbelt over many years, the cumulative risk might be quite large. How good are we in our minds at keeping track of these kinds of risks that gradually accumulate over time? I don't think we really do the cumulative assessment. This was, I think, very evident early
系上安全带，他们也没有受到惩罚，因为他们没有遇到危险。问题在于，在这5万次出行中，你在一次或多次出行中需要安全带的可能性变得相当显著。可能就像三分之一的人会真正遭遇严重事故，并能从安全带中受益。因此，累积概率高到足以证明让人类系安全带是合理的。所以我写了一篇专栏文章，说只有新法律才能产生安全带的使用率。人们开始系安全带是因为这是一项法律，然后它变成了一种规范。所以现在我们有了相对较高的安全带使用率。
on when the seatbelts were first introduced. There were some very high-powered advertising campaigns to try to motivate people to use them. Only about 10 or 15 percent of drivers were wearing seat belts, very low percentage. And so they had these campaigns to get people to buckle up for safety. When you sit down America, show the world you care. Click today with the belt. world you care. Click today with the belt. We'll welcome you. And they didn't work. They had very little impact in thinking about that. Say we take 50,000 trips in a lifetime and these individual trips are really pretty safe so that people were not rewarded by wearing a seat belt. That was a little bit uncomfortable. And if they didn't
你知道，你所说的话中蕴含着深刻的哲学见解，因为我认为，尤其在美国，我们是一个信仰个人自由、自主权和自由的国家，人们希望有一种感觉，即他们正在做出最适合自己的选择。但我认为你在这里讨论的许多关于安全带的例子，或许是最经典的例子，那就是如果你把事情留给个人选择，在这次特定的驾驶中，在我正驾驶的这个特定的星期二，说我的风险其实不是很高，这并不是不理性的，实际上这可能是理性的说法，好吧，我可以放弃安全带，
put it on, they weren't punished either because they didn't need it. The problem is that over 50,000 trips, the likelihood that you'll need a seatbelt on one or more of those trips becomes significant. It might be like one in three people will actually be in a serious accident where they would benefit from a seat belt. So the cumulative probability was high enough to warrant having people wear seat belts. So I wrote an op-ed piece saying that only new laws will produce seat belt use. And people started to wear seat belts because it was a law and then it became kind of a norm. So now we have relatively high seat belt usage.
而且也没发生什么大事。我们的大脑根本不具备应对这类风险的能力，这些风险在许多许多十年中逐渐累积，为了25年后的那一次事件，而那时安全带实际上才真正发挥作用。类似这样的情况，正是你刚才暗指的一部分。你确实需要干预系统，在某些方面保护人们免受他们自身的伤害。你能谈谈这个想法一会儿吗？因为在我看来，这是你所做工作的哲学含义之一吗？是的，你通过科学、通过收集数据获得了这种更广阔的视角，
You know, there's a deep philosophical insight here and what you're saying, because I think especially in the United States, we are a country that believes in individual liberty and autonomy and freedom and people want to have the sense that they are making the choices that are best for them. But I think the many examples you've talked about here in the seat belts, perhaps the classic example, is how if you leave things up to individual choice, it is not irrational to say on this particular drive, on this particular Tuesday that I'm driving, my risk is actually not very high, and it might actually be the rational thing to say, okay, I can forego the seat belt
这可以显示这些风险是如何累积并影响个人和群体的。吸烟也是如此。也就是说，抽下一支烟的风险真的会显著危害你。我的意思是，事情不是这样的。带来的危害是吸烟数千支香烟的累积危害，这会导致患肺癌以及许多疾病的风险显著增加。鉴于来自许多来源的持续和不断增加的证据，该委员会的判断是，
and nothing much happens. And our minds simply are not equipped to deal with these kinds of risks, gradually accumulating over many, many decades for that one event, you know, 25 years from now, when the seat belt actually is really useful. And situations like this, this is part of what you were alluding to a second ago. You really do need the intervention of systems that protect people in some ways from themselves. Can you talk about this idea moment because it seems to me that that's one of the philosophical implications of the work that you've done? Yes, and you get this broader perspective through science, through collecting data, and
吸烟大大增加了某些特定疾病的死亡率以及总体死亡率。这可以通过数据、统计数据来证明，无论对个人还是对群体而言。但在个人层面上，接下来的这支烟或接下来的这次驾驶不太可能会给你带来问题。我们对风险的分析方法与对风险的情感反应之间的一些不匹配，是由我们在头脑中进行某些数学运算的能力不足造成的。
that can show how these risks accumulate and affect both individuals and populations. The same thing happens with cigarette smoking. That is the risk that smoking this next cigarette is really going to harm you significantly. I mean, it doesn't work that way. The harm that comes is the cumulative harm of smoking, you know, thousands of cigarettes that leads to quite a significant increase in the risk of not just lung cancer, but many diseases. In view of the continuing and mounting evidence for many sources, it is a judgment of the
昨天我在寻找这方面的例子时，偶然发现了一个有趣的谜题。如果你拿一张纸并把它对折，它的厚度现在是最初的两倍。然后如果你再次对折，它现在的厚度就是原纸张的四倍。这个谜题是，如果你有无穷无尽的纸，你必须将它对折多少次才能得到一座一直延伸到月球的塔？
committee that cigarette smoking contributes substantially to mortality from certain specific diseases and to the overall death rate. And it can be demonstrated through data, through statistics, both for the individual and for the population. But at the individual level, this very next cigarette or this very next drive is not likely to be a problem for you. Some mismatches between our analytical approach to risk and our emotional response to risk comes about because of our inability to do certain kinds of math in our heads.
当我第一次看到这个谜题时，我想答案一定大约是，你知道，就像你必须折叠十亿次一样。而正确答案是45次，仅仅45次折叠，你就能得到一座基本上从地球一直延伸到月球的塔，那可是四分之一百万英里远。保罗，你能谈谈为什么人们经常难以理解指数增长的本质，即二变成四，四变成八，八变成十六，以此类推？以及这如何塑造了我们的风险感知？是的，这对人脑来说是一个非常有趣的挑战。20世纪70年代在荷兰进行的实验非常清楚地证明了这一点，当时人们被赋予了一系列关于污染不断增加的数值测量，
I was looking for examples of this yesterday and came by an interesting puzzle. If you take a piece of paper and you fold it over, it now has double the thickness it had at first. And then if you fold it over again, it's now four times as thick as the original sheet. And the puzzle is, if you had an endless amount of paper, how many times would you have to fold it over to get a tower that stretches all the way to the moon?
污染每年翻倍或三倍，他们被问及10年后这会达到什么程度。他们发现的是，人们从这种指数增长开始时的极低水平按一条直线进行预测，并大大低估了这会导致的结果。因此，指数增长的标志，以及使其如此具有挑战性和潜伏性的原因在于，它在开始时看起来非常良性，尽管它呈指数变化，但数字仍然很小。而发生的情况是，突然之间，它像爆发并以极大数字压垮我们的火灾一样怒吼而起。
And when I first saw the puzzle, I guess the answer must be about, you know, like you have to fold it a billion times. And the correct answer is 45, just 45 falls, and you get a tower that basically stretches all the way from the earth to the moon, which is a quarter of a million miles away. Can you talk a moment, Paul, about how people often experience difficulty appreciating the nature of exponential growth, where two becomes four, four becomes eight, eight becomes 16 and so on. And how does shapes are perception of risk? Yes, this is very interesting challenge for the human brain and some experiments that were done in the 1970s and the Netherlands demonstrated this very clearly where people were given a series of numerical measures of pollution
所以我们无法预料它会以多快速度爆发。我想在COVID-19大流行的背景下谈谈指数增长。在3月初，我想是在2020年3月9日，纽约市长白思豪（Bill de Blasio）对即将到来的大流行病发表了这样的看法：有些地方像意大利正在大规模关闭学校。这不在我们的菜单上。
increasing. And the pollution was doubling or tripling every year, and they were asked, where will this be after 10 years? And what they found was that people projected in a straight line from this very low level at the beginning of this exponential growth and greatly underestimated where this was leading. So the hallmark of exponential growth and what makes it so challenging and insidious in a way is that it looks very benign at the beginning even though it is changing exponentially, the numbers are still small. And what happens is suddenly, roars up like a fire that erupts and overwhelms us
有没有可能发生这种情况的理论场景？当然有，但它离我们现在的情况很近吗？没有。所以这是在3月9日，保罗。纽约市在一周后的3月16日关闭了公立学校。我认为这在某种程度上说明了你刚才所说的话，也就是说，即使你是一个怀着最好意图、拥有大量数据的公众官员，也很难真正理解大流行病的增长速度可以有多么惊人。绝对是这样。世界各地的政府都很慢才意识到，当他们少量的病例开始呈指数级增长时会发生什么。
with very high numbers. So we don't anticipate how quickly it's going to explode. I want to talk about exponential growth in the context of the COVID-19 pandemic. In early March, I believe it was on March 9th, 2020, New York City Mayor Bill de Blasio had this to say about the coming pandemic. Some places like Italy are doing mass school closures. That's not on the menu here.
因此，我认为人们在反应上普遍存在延迟，幸运的是并非到处如此，但大多数国家反应迟缓，因为数字很小，略有增长，而且看起来并没有那么糟糕。而当我们真正开始认真对待它时，它已经失控了。你认为大脑的什么特质使得我们难以理解指数增长？嗯，可能是因为它与直线增长相比相对罕见。也就是说，比如计数，计数是一个线性系统。
Is there a theoretical scenario where that could happen, of course, but is it anywhere near to where we are now? No. So this was on March 9th, Paul. New York City closed its public schools one week later on March 16th. And I think that speaks in some ways to what you were just saying, which is that it's really hard, even if you're a public official with the best of intentions, and you have a lot of data, to actually truly appreciate how staggeringly fast a pandemic can grow. Absolutely. Governments all over the world were slow to appreciate what was going to happen when their small numbers of cases began to grow exponentially.
我们对以线性方式增长的事物比对呈指数增长的事物要熟悉得多。在许多方面，我们的大脑在与风险的数学进行斗争。指数增长对我们来说很难概念化。正如我们之前听到的那样，当我们的情绪成为方程式的一部分时，1%的风险与99%的风险之间的区别就变得难以考虑进去了。然后是控制权的问题，以及我们是否觉得是自己在选择承担哪些风险。50多年前，研究人员钱斯塔（Chancestar）发现了一个奇怪的现象。
And so I think there was a general delay in responding, not everywhere, fortunately, but the majority of nations were slow to react because the numbers were small, increasing slightly, and it didn't look all that bad. And by the time we really start to take it seriously, it's out of control. What do you think it is about the mind that makes it difficult for us to appreciate exponential growth? Well, probably because it is relatively rare compared to straight line growth. That is, like counting, counting is a linear system.
与不涉及个人选择的活动相比，人们愿意为自己选择的活动接受大得多的风险。他们对滑雪或蹦极等活动接受了更高的风险水平，但在建筑安全或食品防腐剂的使用等方面，却发现类似水平的风险是不可接受的。保罗和其他研究人员在后续研究中完善了这个想法。但关于个人控制重要性的这一核心发现，可能有助于我们理解为什么有些人说他们不担心感染COVID-19病毒，却担心COVID-19疫苗的安全性。
And we're much more familiar with things that grow in a linear way than those that grow exponentially. In so many ways, our minds struggle with a mathematics of risk. Exponential growth is hard for us to conceptualize. And as we heard earlier, the difference between a 1% risk and a 99% risk becomes difficult to take into account when our emotions become part of the equation. Then there's the issue of control and whether we feel like we're the ones making choices about which risks to take. More than 50 years ago, the researcher Chancestar discovered something curious.
当你去餐馆时，你觉得自己有控制权。你说服自己病毒的风险很小。但你无法控制疫苗是如何制造的。你必须信任由你从未见过的科学家所进行的研究结果。保罗说，我们的控制感在我们的风险感知中起着重要作用。曾经有人给我举过这样一个例子，假设你正在切一条面包。你会把手指放得离刀有多近？
People were willing to accept far greater risks for activities that they chose over activities that did not involve personal choice. They accepted a higher level of risk for, say, skiing or bungee jumping, but found a similar level of risk unacceptable when it came to things like building safety or the use of preservatives in food. Paul and other researchers have refined this idea in subsequent studies. But this core finding about the importance of personal control may help us to understand why some people say they are not worried about becoming ill with the COVID-19 virus, but are worried about the safety of the COVID-19 vaccine.
假设另一个人在切面包。你会把那些脚（注：应为手指）放得有多近？你可能不会放得那么近。我认为这是控制感的一个很好的例子。我认为这是驾驶中的一个非常重要的因素，司机觉得他们在控制风险，因为他们在控制速度和其他方面。
You feel you have control when you go to a restaurant. You convince yourself the risk of the virus is small. But you don't have control over how a vaccine is made. You have to trust the results of studies conducted by scientists whom you will never meet. Paul says our sense of control plays a significant role in our perceptions of risk. Someone once gave me an example, supposing that you're slicing a loaf of bread. And how close to the knife would you put your fingers?
他们没有意识到情境中所有不受他们控制的要素，比如状况、道路危险或其他司机将要做什么。你认为其中许多偏见的根源是什么？我们大脑运作方式与现代生活给我们带来的挑战之间的这种不匹配。当我们处于演化的早期阶段、大脑正在形成时，我们很大程度上是由当时面临的经验塑造的，这些经验与那些近在咫尺、就在我们眼前的亲密事物有关，比如潜伏在灌木丛中的动物或充满敌意的部落。我们对数量相对较少的事物有着那种敏感性，并且
And supposing that someone else was slicing the bread. How close would you put those feet? You probably wouldn't be as close. And I think that's a nice example of the sense of control. I think it's very important element in driving, where the driver feels that they are controlling the risk because they're controlling the speed and other aspects.
可以通过我们的感官直接感知。在现代世界中，危害要多样得多。其中许多是无形的，比如与细菌或病毒有关的事物，以及我们不易看到的事物。那些离我们有一段距离但最终会影响我们的事情。比如与气候变化有关的事物，那里的问题似乎仍然相当遥远，是一件将会发生的事。那件事正在发生，也许在别处发生在他人的身上。所以现代世界拥有与古代世界完全不同的一系列危害，
They don't realize all the elements of the situations that are not under their control, like the condition, you know, road hazards or what other drivers are going to do. Where do you think the origins for many of these biases are, this mismatch between the way our brains operate and the challenges that modern life places before us. When we were earlier in our phase of evolution and our brain was forming, we were shaped very much by the experience that we faced at that time, which had to do with things that were kind of up close and personal things that were right in front of us, like an animal lurking in the bushes or hostile tribe. We had that kind of sensitivity to things that were relatively small in number, and we
从某种意义上说，我们的许多思维模式都是在山洞里形成的。是的，我记得几个月前去树林里散步，在小径的某处，你知道，我记得自己向后猛地一跳，你知道，我低头一看，看到有一条蛇，你知道，就在我前方五英尺处。我被自己对那种威胁的反应速度所震撼，你知道，它几乎是瞬时的，感觉几乎就像是一个反射。在COVID大流行的所有月份里，我从未经历过像看到那条蛇时感到的那种恐惧。
could sense directly through our senses. In the modern world, the hazards are far more diverse. Many of them are invisible, like things that have to do with bacteria or viruses and things that we can't easily see. Things that happen at a distance from us, but at some point will affect us. Things like it related to climate change, where the problem seems still fairly distant, something that's going to happen. That's happening, perhaps elsewhere to other people. So the modern world has a whole different array of hazards from the ancient world,
当然，当你细想时，COVID的风险可能比那条蛇对我的风险大得多，因为野外、树林中、郊区社区的大多数蛇可能相对安全。但石器时代的大脑在某种程度上仍然留存在我的大脑中，
and a lot of these modes of thinking were shaped in the cave, so to speak. Yeah, I remember going for a walk a few months ago in the woods and at one point in the trail, you know, I remember sort of leaping backwards and you know, I looked down and I saw that there was a snake, you know, five feet in front of me. And I was struck by the the speed of my response to that threat was just, you know, it was almost instantaneous, it almost felt like a, like a reflex. And through all of the months of the COVID pandemic, I have never experienced a moment of fear like I felt when I saw that snake.
使我对蛇的风险的警惕性远远高于对可能对我他人造成伤害的这种无形病毒的风险的警惕。是的，这再次体现了很久以前存在的、塑造了我们大脑形成方式的危害与当今风险之间的差异。你所说的话的另一个变体是，如果你面前看到的不是蛇，而是听到灌木丛中传来不祥的声音。然后问题是，你会停下来分析这个声音，并在内心争论这是否真的是一件你需要担心的事，还是你只是把它当作听起来很可怕的事情然后走开。
And of course, when you think about it, the risk of COVID is probably much greater than the risk that that snake posed me because most snakes, of course, in the wild, in a woods, in suburban communities are probably gonna be relatively safe. But there's something in some ways about the Stone Age brain that is remained in my brain,
而很可能会发生的是，你接受了第一种反应。这是我的同事丹尼尔·韦斯特法尔（Daniel Westfall）和我讨论过的问题：我们的感觉没有守门员来引导我们分析那些向我们传递感觉的信息。我们只是按其本原接受它。大脑让这些感觉进入，我们对它们做出反应。我们不像审查论据那样审查我们的感觉。我认为这可以追溯到很久以前，
where I'm much more vigilant to the risk of a snake than I am to the risk of this invisible virus that could do me and others harm. Yes, again, a difference between hazards that existed a long time ago that shaped the way our brains form than the risks of today. Another variation on what you said was, if instead of seeing the snake in front of you, you had heard an ominous sound in the bushes. And then the question is, do you stop and you analyze the sound and debate with yourself as to whether this is really something you should worry about, or you just take it as something that sounds scary and kind of move away from it.
这在当时是非常具适应性的。这是有充分理由的，因为如果——正如你所指出的——如果你真的停下来分析每一个威胁，并在每次听到灌木丛中有低吼声时都画出一个成本效益计算图，你很可能早就死了。是的，不仅你的计算很可能是错的，因为要做这些计算实在是太难了。
And what likely will happen is that you accept the first reaction. And this is something that my colleague Daniel Westfall and I have discussed that our feelings, there's no gatekeeper that leads us to analyze information that conveys feelings in us. We just take it for what it is. And the brain lets these feelings in, and we react to them. We don't vet our feelings the way we vet arguments. And I think this goes way back, something
而很可能会发生的情况是，你接受了第一反应。这也是我的同事丹尼尔·韦斯特法尔和我讨论过的一个问题，即我们的情感，没有把关人来引导我们去分析那些在我们心中激起情感的信息。我们只是按其本面接受它。大脑让这些情感进入，然后我们对此做出反应。我们不会像审视论点那样去审视自己的情感。我认为这可以追溯到很久以前，某种
that was very adaptive a long time ago. And for good reason, because if if again, as you point out, if you actually stopped and analyzed every threat and drew up a cost-benefit calculation, every time you heard a growl in the bushes, likelihood is you'd be dead. Yes, not only would your calculations likely be wrong, because it's so hard to do those calculations.
在很久以前非常具有适应性的东西。这是有充分理由的，因为如果——正如你所指出的——如果你真的停下来分析每一个威胁，并在每次听到灌木丛中有低吼声时做出一份成本效益计算，你很有可能会没命。是的，不仅你的计算很可能是错的，因为要做这些计算实在是太难了。
But, yeah, you say, you may not survive. You have to just move fast. You know, there are many risks where if I take the risk, I'm the one who is bearing the cost of that risk. So if I decide to go mountain climbing or base jumping, I'm the one who's incurring the risk. Now presumably others are affected as well if something happens to me, but to a large extent, you know, I bear the consequences of my actions. That logic breaks down when it comes to the risk of something like a pandemic, where my actions, in fact, might affect the well-being of other people.
但是，对，正如你所说，你可能无法生存。你必须迅速行动。你知道，有很多风险，如果我承担风险，我就是承担该风险成本的人。因此，如果我决定去爬山或进行低空跳伞，我就是承担风险的人。现在假设如果我发生什么事，其他人也会受到影响，但在很大程度上，你知道，我要承担我行为的后果。当遇到像大流行病这样的风险时，这种逻辑就行不通了，在那种情况下，我的行为实际上可能会影响其他人的福祉。
Economists sometimes call these phenomena negative externalities. So in other words, my actions that I'm undertaking freely might affect somebody else's ability to be free and their ability to do what it is that they want to do. But if our minds are not very good at appreciating the things that are risky even to us, how effective can they be in appreciating the things that are risky to other people?
经济学家有时将这些现象称为负外部性。换句话说，我自由承担的行为可能会影响其他人获得自由的能力以及他们做自己想做的事情的能力。但是，如果我们的大脑很不善于认识到甚至对自己来说都有风险的事情，那么它们在认识到对其他人有风险的事情时会有多大效果呢？
It's particularly true that we can't sense that when the consequences are not direct. So some things that we do that have collective consequences are, for example, you know, stopping at red lights, where if you Violate those what you get to your destination a little quicker if you don't stop at red lights, but you know, there'll be massive increase in collisions and deaths, so which is very obvious. A harm, but you get good feedback on the harm that your individualism is producing. The problem with COVID that makes it so insidious and difficult is the fact that protecting yourself and others by wearing a mask, social distancing, staying home rather than going to school or to the workplace, you don't have the sense
当后果不是直接的时，我们感觉不到这一点，这尤其真实。例如，我们做的一些具有集体后果的事情，比如，你知道的，在红灯前停车，如果你违反了这些规定，如果不红灯停，你可能会快一点到达目的地，但你知道，碰撞和死亡人数会大幅增加，所以这是显而易见的。这是一种伤害，但你能从你的个人主义所产生的伤害中得到很好的反馈。COVID带来的问题使其如此隐蔽和困难，事实是，通过戴口罩、保持社交距离、呆在家裡而不是去学校或工作场所来保护自己和他人，你并没有这种感觉
that you are creating harm when you are violating those because you don't see the harm immediately or directly. And we rely heavily on kind of what's right in front of our eyes in terms of sensing risk. We don't see the damages that are caused, but we feel the benefits of not doing these things. And we get to hang out with our friends and go to restaurants and bars and work which we need to do.
当你违反这些规定时，你是在造成伤害，因为你没有立即或直接看到这种伤害。在感知风险方面，我们很大程度上依赖于眼前看到的东西。我们看不到造成的损害，但我们感受到了不做这些事情的好处。我们可以和朋友出去玩，去餐馆、酒吧，去我们需要做的工作。
So, we feel the benefits of doing the wrong thing. We don't see the benefits of doing the right thing. And that's a recipe that leads even the most responsible people to ease off over time. Yeah. And of course, when you think about this from the point of view of natural selection, the reason viruses have thrived among human populations for thousands of years is really because they've taken advantage of how our minds work. Yes, it's interesting. Well, they succeed when they have characteristics that take advantage of our cognitive limitations.
所以，我们感受到了做错事的好处。我们看不到做好事的好处。这个秘诀甚至会让最负责任的人随着时间的推移而松懈。是的。当然，当你从自然选择的角度来思考这个问题时，病毒在人类群体中繁衍了数千年，其原因确实是它们利用了我们大脑的工作方式。是的，这很有趣。嗯，当它们具有利用我们认知局限性的特征时，它们就会成功。
And in fact, as we go to more and more remote parts of the earth and start to inhabit rainforests and other places in the climate changes, we are perhaps coming into contact with more of these viruses that here to four, we haven't had contact with. And that's kind of a worry in the future. But it's certainly the case that with COVID, COVID
事实上，随着我们走向地球越来越偏远的地区，开始居住在雨林和其他地方以及气候变化，我们也许正在接触更多以前我们从未接触过的病毒。这在未来有点令人担忧。但毫无疑问，对于COVID来说，COVID
is adapted to thrive in ways that are very difficult for humans to combat. Yeah, I mean, I know the virus has not been designed by an evil psychologist. But sometimes it feels as if the virus has been designed by an evil psychologist when you see how it's taking advantage of the fat abilities in our cognitive architecture. And the very fact that the harm can be spread invisibly makes it ambiguous enough
经过调整，能够以人类极难对抗的方式繁衍。是的，我的意思是，我知道这个病毒不是由邪恶的心理学家设计的。但有时你会觉得，当你看到它是如何利用我们认知架构中的缺陷能力时，这病毒就像是由一个邪恶心理学家设计的。伤害可以隐形传播这一事实，使其变得足够含糊
that politicians can then play on that to manipulate us to say that it is really not a serious problem. to manipulate us to say that it is really not a serious problem. When we come back, Paul explains why our brains have an easier time mourning one death rather than tens of thousands of deaths. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've seen how many subtle biases shape what makes us afraid. We are more likely to feel things that do not involve activities of our own choosing. We are less likely to notice dangers when they grow exponentially or add up cumulatively.
政客们随后可以利用这一点来操纵我们，声称这根本不是一个严重的问题。来操纵我们，声称这真的不是一个严重的问题。当我们回来时，保罗将解释为什么我们的大脑更容易哀悼一个人的死亡，而不是成千上万人的死亡。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们已经看到，许多微妙的偏见塑造了我们恐惧的原因。我们更容易对不涉及我们自己选择的活动的事情产生感觉。当危险呈指数级增长或累积增加时，我们不太可能注意到它们。
Paul, you've done a lot of work exploring how the same phenomenon might play out in the context of compassion, our ability to care about others. Can you talk about the phenomenon of psychic numbing, please? Yes, I started to look at that when I became concerned about the failure of the world to respond to the genocide that was happening in Rwanda, where 800,000 people were murdered in about a hundred days, and the world knew it was happening and turned a blind eye to it, you know, refused to intervene in any way. And I started to study that, and one way to study that was to look at, you know, why we help some people who are in danger and not others.
保罗，你做了大量的工作来探讨同样的现象如何在同情心——我们关心他人的能力——的背景下发挥作用。请你谈谈麻木心理的现象好吗？是的，当我开始关注世界未能对卢旺达发生的种族灭绝做出反应时，我开始研究这个问题，当时大约一百天内有80万人被谋杀，全世界都知道这件事却视而不见，你知道，拒绝以任何方式进行干预。我开始研究这个问题，研究方法之一就是看看，你知道，为什么我们帮助某些处于危险中的人而不帮助其他人。
And we found that this was very much related to how many people there were at risk. And again, we had been sensitized to the notion that our sense of risk was driven by our feelings. So we looked at how feelings work in this context as well. And we realized that one life we believe is immensely important and valuable to protect. And we make an emotional connection to an individual in need and we'll then do a lot to protect that person or to rescue them
我们发现这与处于危险中的人数密切相关。同样，我们已经意识到这样一个观念，即我们的风险感是由我们的感受驱动的。因此，我们也研究了感情在这种情况下是如何运作的。我们意识到，我们相信一个生命对于保护而言具有巨大的重要性和价值。我们与需要帮助的个人建立情感联系，然后我们会做很多事情来保护那个人或拯救他们
but that it doesn't scale up. Why, if we value individual lives so greatly, do we do so little to protect thousands or millions of lives at risk? That was the puzzle and we started doing experiments to help us understand that. So some of the experiments that you've done have looked at what happens in people's minds as you expand the number of victims of a tragedy. And what's striking is that we're not talking about very large numbers here, even at fairly
但这并不能按比例放大。为什么如果我们如此高度重视个体生命，我们却为保护成千上万或数百万处于危险中的生命做得这么少？这就是谜题，我们开始做实验来帮助我们理解这一点。因此，你做的一些实验着眼于随着悲剧受害者人数的增加，人们的心智会发生什么变化。令人震惊的是，我们在这里谈论的并不是非常庞大的数字，即使在相当小的数字下
small numbers, our ability to empathize almost seems to shrink as the numbers seem to grow. Talk about some of those experiments, Paul. Yes. almost seems to shrink as the number seemed to grow. Talk about some of those experiments, Paul. Yes, we asked people to donate money on behalf of children who were facing starvation. And we found that as the number of children at risk increased the propensity of an individual to donate money to help them, did not grow as the number of potential victims grew,
人数很少，而随着数字的增长，我们的同理心几乎会缩小。保罗，谈谈其中一些实验吧。是的，我们要求人们以面临饥饿的儿童的名义捐款。我们发现，随着面临危险的儿童人数增加，个人捐款帮助他们的倾向并没有随着潜在受害者人数的增长而增长，
but rather was strongest for a the number of potential victims grew, but rather was strongest for a small number of individuals and then either flattened out or in some case it even declined and we had a phrase for that we said the more who died the less we care. We don't respond proportionally as the needs get greater and there are several reasons that we discovered for that. One is this notion of psychic numbing that when things become large and become statistics, we don't get the same emotional connection to the people at risk that we do when there's only a few of them. And so as the numbers increase, we say that statistics are human beings with the tears dried off.
相反，对于潜在受害者人数较少的情况，这种倾向最强，然后趋于平缓，或者在某些情况下甚至下降，我们对此有一个说法，我们说死的人越多，我们越不在乎。随着需求的增加，我们的反应并不成比例，我们为此发现了几个原因。一个是这种心理麻木的概念，当事情变得庞大并变成统计数据时，我们不会对处于危险中的人产生与只有少数人时相同的情感联系。因此，随着数字的增加，我们说统计数据就是擦干眼泪的人类。
You don't get the same emotional reaction to the numbers that you do to the individual or small numbers of people. And of course all of us have experienced this in the course of the COVID-19 pandemic. Even those of us who want to exercise empathy and compassion, it just simply isn't possible to muster the same sense of tragedy when the death toll goes from 221,355 to 221,356. That extra death doesn't count in our minds because our minds simply are not calibrated
你对这些数字不会产生像对个人或少数人那样相同的情感反应。当然，我们所有人在COVID-19大流行的过程中都经历过这一点。即使是我们这些想要运用同理心和同情心的人，当死亡人数从221355人增加到221356人时，也根本无法产生那种同样的悲剧感。多出的那个死亡在我们的脑海中并不算数，因为我们的大脑根本没有校准
to deal with that level of tragedy. You could have added not one life, but 10,000 or 20,000 lives there, and again, you feel the same. It's just a big number if we don't see the ill people around us or know them or if we don't feel personally vulnerable, the statistics don't move us as they should. So many years ago, the philosopher Peter Singer came up with a thought experiment that we've talked about before in Hidden Brain.
来应对那种程度的悲剧。你本可以加上不仅仅是一个生命，而是10,000或20,000个生命，但你仍然会有同样的感受。这只是一个巨大的数字，如果我们看不到周围生病的人，不认识他们，或者如果我们不觉得自己在个人层面是脆弱的，这些统计数据就无法像它们应该的那样触动我们。许多年前，哲学家彼得·辛格提出过一个思想实验，我们在《隐藏的大脑》中之前讨论过。
And very simply, the thought experiment is imagine you're walking by the side of a pond and you see a child drowning in the pond. And you can jump in and save the child at no risk to your own life, but you have to act quickly. And if you act quickly and jump in the pond, you're going to ruin a very fine pair of shoes you're wearing. And the question that Peter Singer asks, you know, most people say, of course, I would jump in the pond to save the child's life, a child's life is worth more than my pair of
非常简单，这个思想实验是想象你走在池塘边，你看到一个孩子在池塘里溺水。你可以跳进去救这个孩子，而不会危及你自己的生命，但你必须迅速行动。如果你迅速行动并跳进池塘，你会毁掉你脚上穿着的一双非常好的鞋子。彼得·辛格提出的问题是，你知道，大多数人会说，我当然会跳进池塘去救孩子的命，一个孩子的命比我的一双
shoes. The question that Peter Singer asks is, well, in that case, why would you not donate $200 if you're money to save the life of a child halfway around the world? Because it's the same trade-off in that case, you know, a child life, or she's $200. You came up with a heartbreaking twist on that thought experiment that in some ways is very revealing about the conversation we're having about how empathy and compassion work when numbers start to get larger than one.
鞋子更有价值。彼得·辛格提出的问题是，既然如此，为什么如果你有钱，却不肯捐出200美元来拯救地球另一端一个孩子的生命？因为在这种情况下，这是相同的权衡，你知道的，一个孩子的生命，或者一双200美元的鞋子。你对那个思想实验提出了一个令人心碎的转折，在某些方面，这非常揭示了我们正在进行的关于当数字开始变得大于一时同理心和同情心如何起作用的对话。
Tell me about the refinement to the thought experiment, Paul. We ask people to imagine that they're walking by this pond, and they see a child in the water drowning, and they're about to jump in and risk their own lives. And then they see that often the distance, there's a second child also in danger of drowning. And the question is, well, would you not go into the water
保罗，请告诉我你对这个思想实验的改进。我们要求人们想象他们走在池塘边，看到一个孩子在水中溺水，他们正要跳进去并冒着生命危险。然后他们看到远处有第二个孩子也处于溺水的危险之中。问题是，难道你不会进入水中
and rescue the child that is nearby because there's another child that you can't rescue? And you would say, of course not, I mean, I can rescue this child. Let's do it. But what we find in experiments is actually that people do get demotivated from helping people, they can help by the bad feelings they get when they realize that there's others that they cannot help. the bad feelings they get when they realize that there's others that they cannot help. So what's going on here is that we help others not only because they need our help, but also we feel good about doing that. We're doing the right thing and we can do it. And when you're made aware of others who you cannot help, this creates negative feelings
去营救附近的那个孩子，因为还有另一个你无法营救的孩子？你会说，当然不会，我的意思是，我可以营救这个孩子。我们干吧。但我们在实验中发现，实际上，当人们意识到还有其他人他们无法营救时，他们会因为产生的坏情绪而对帮助他人失去动力。当他们意识到还有其他人他们无法营救时，他们会产生不好的情绪。所以这里发生的事情是，我们帮助别人不仅是因为他们需要我们的帮助，而且我们这样做也会感觉良好。我们在做正确的事，而且我们能够做到。当你意识到还有其他人你无法帮助时，这会产生负面情绪
that come in and mix in with the good feeling and dampen the good feeling you have about what you cannot help. This creates negative feelings that come in and mix in with the good feeling and dampen the good feeling you have about what you can do. So then you're no longer do it. So it obviously in a real situation when you're right there with a child, you're not gonna be demotivated. But if this is a more subtle kind of thing where you're asked to donate to a charity
这些情绪介入并与良好的感觉混合在一起，并削弱了你对无法帮助的事情的良好感觉。这会产生负面情绪，介入并与良好的感觉混合在一起，并削弱你对你能做的事情的良好感觉。所以你就不再这样做了。因此，在现实情况中，当你和孩子在一起时，你显然不会失去动力。但如果这是一种更微妙的事情，即你被要求向慈善机构捐款
on behalf of starving children like this one. And then by the way, you're told that this is a big problem with starvation in this region that there are thousands or millions of children starving. You should even be more motivated to help this child. We found an experiment that the donations dropped in half when people were made aware of the fact that this child that they could help was one of many. This is crazy. You know, you should not be demotivated from doing what you can do by the fact that you can't do it all. Do what you can do. You know, you can look at what's happened with the COVID pandemic almost as a dress rehearsal
以像这个孩子一样面临饥饿的儿童的名义。然后顺便告诉你，这个地区的饥饿问题非常严重，有成千上万或数百万的儿童在挨饿。你应该更有动力去帮助这个孩子。我们在实验中发现，当人们意识到这个他们可以帮助的孩子只是其中之一时，捐款额减少了一半。这太疯狂了。你知道，你不应该因为你无法做到全部而对做你能做的事失去动力。做你能做的事。你知道的，你可以把COVID大流行的发生几乎看作是一场彩排
for even more serious challenges that we might face collectively in the years to come. I'm wondering if you can connect our discussion about risk to the challenge of dealing with a problem like climate change. How do the workings of our minds predict what we have done and what we might be failing to do? Yes, that's a very interesting question. So first, COVID spreads exponentially, and the same thing may happen to us with climate change. That is sure it's on a different scale, but the processes that are contributing to climate change in terms of the build-up of certain types of pollutants and the changes in temperature are growing exponentially. And the hallmark of an exponential growth process
为我们未来几年可能集体面临的更严峻的挑战做准备。我想知道你是否能将我们关于风险的讨论与应对气候变化等问题的挑战联系起来。我们大脑的运作方式如何预测我们已经做了什么以及我们可能没有做的事情？是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题。首先，COVID呈指数级传播，同样的事情也可能在气候变化方面发生在我们身上。当然，它的规模不同，但在某些类型污染物的积聚和温度变化方面，导致气候变化的进程正在呈指数级增长。指数增长过程的标志
is that the really severe, unacceptable, unlivable consequences will be here more quickly than we think, unless we pay attention to the scientists who are showing us with the data that this is happening. Just like scientists were showing us with the data that COVID was growing exponentially, but we didn't take that seriously. We have to do the same thing with regard to climate change.
那就是，除非我们关注那些用数据向我们表明这一情况正在发生的科学家，否则真正严重、不可接受、不适宜居住的后果将会比我们想象的更快到来。就像科学家用数据向我们表明COVID正呈指数级增长，但我们并没有认真对待一样。在气候变化方面我们也必须这样做。
We talked a little while earlier about the idea of externalities where my actions that I'm undertaking with autonomy might affect you. And it's clear that there are things I would not do to harm you if I thought that they would harm you. I wouldn't come up and punch you in the face. But I might say, what's the harm in my going to a bar? How is that possibly gonna affect Paul?
我们不久前讨论过外部性的概念，即我自主进行的行动可能会影响到你。很明显，如果我认为我的行为会伤害你，我不会做伤害你的事。我不会走过去揍你的脸。但我可能会说，我去酒吧有什么害处？这怎么可能影响到保罗？
Because I can't see the chain that causes you harm. And I'm wondering in some ways of climate change sort of puts that on steroids. Because here, the externalities are not just other people. They're not just people living in other countries, but they are people who are not yet born, who will be inhabiting the earth, you know, 50 or 100, 200 years from now. If our minds are not well calibrated to think about the well-being of other people who are
因为我看不到造成你伤害的链条。我想知道气候变化在某种程度上是否给这一点打上了强心剂。因为在这里，外部性不仅仅是其他人。他们不仅仅是生活在其他国家的人，而且是尚未出生的人，他们将在50年、100年、200年後居住在这个地球上。如果我们的大脑没有很好地校准去考虑生活在我们隔壁
living next to us, or in the next city, or the next country, you know, surely it must be even harder for our minds to contemplate the well-being of people who haven't yet arrived on the planet. Yes, I think you're right, because we will devalue the lives of people who are currently living, but when they don't even exist yet, then it's even easier to devalue them. And it's not necessarily that we are deliberately saying that their lives don't matter, because if you ask people who are doing things that are harmful to the climate, are these future lives of people in future generations, are they important?
或者在下一个城市、下一个国家的人们的福祉，那么毫无疑问，对于我们的大脑来说，考虑那些尚未到达这个星球的人们的福祉肯定更加困难。是的，我认为你是对的，因为我们会贬低当前生活的人们的生命，而当他们甚至还不存在时，贬低他们就更容易了。这并不一定意味着我们是在故意说他们的生命不重要，因为如果你问那些正在做对气候有害的事情的人，未来几代人的这些未来生命，他们重要吗？
We would say, yes, of course, they are important. And what we found is that there's often a disconnect between our values and the actions. And that comes from the fact that when we have to act, we've got a conflict between you protecting unborn future generations versus getting the near-term conveniences and comforts that we get from doing the wrong thing to the environment. And so we act in ways that contradict our values. And we have to be aware of that.
我们会说，是的，当然，他们很重要。我们发现，我们的价值观和行动之间往往存在脱节。这是因为当我们必须采取行动时，我们在保护未出生的未来几代人与获得因对环境做错事而带来的近期便利和舒适之间存在冲突。因此，我们的行事方式与我们的价值观相矛盾。我们必须意识到这一点。
And that implies that we have to do more than just educate people about the importance of protecting future generations. We also have to have enforcement of behaviors and, you know, through regulations, we have to enforce safe practices. We also have to provide motivation and economic incentives for doing the right thing, you know, and creating jobs in industries that protect the environment. So we have to recognize the fact that we need these external, often led by government and industry, the carrots and the sticks to produce and maintain a climate-friendly behavior that just creating a moral obligation by itself is not going to do it. Yeah, I mean, it's interesting you've been studying these issues for, you know, some four decades now, Paul, and there must be a part of you that's a little disheartened
这意味着我们不仅要教育人们保护未来几代人的重要性。我们还必须通过法规来强制执行行为，你知道的，我们必须强制执行安全做法。我们还必须为做正确的事提供动机和经济激励，你知道的，并在保护环境的行业中创造就业机会。因此，我们必须认识到我们需要这些外部的、通常由政府和行业主导的胡萝卜加大棒来产生和维持对气候友好的行为，单靠创造道德义务是无法做到这一点的。是的，我的意思是，有趣的是，你研究这些问题已经大约四十年了，保罗，当你看到这些真知灼见在面对全球大流行病或气候变化时实际上被运用得如此之少时，你的内心一定有一部分会感到有点沮丧
when you see how little these insights have actually been used in the face of, you know, a global pandemic or climate change. What gives you hope as you look out at the landscape in terms of, you know, having these ideas actually applied to turn things for the better. It's a challenge and I do get energized by facing challenges. Also I think the information environment is different now so that hopefully the awareness of the findings that we're coming up with and their implications can be spread far and
当你放眼这些想法实际上被应用以扭转局面向更好方向发展的景观时，是什么给了你希望。这是一个挑战，面对挑战确实让我充满了活力。我也认为现在的信息环境不同了，希望我们得出的研究结果及其影响的意识能够迅速广泛地传播开来。
wide very quickly. And I find it an exciting challenge to try to synthesize and communicate the knowledge of the judgment and decision-making community to address these problems that are global in scope and potentially catastrophic. Paul Slovak is a psychologist at the University of Oregon. To learn more about his work, go to erismaticofcompassion.org. Paul, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. You're very welcome, Shankar, it's my pleasure. How's your? Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz,
我发现尝试综合和传达判断和决策群体的知识，以解决这些在全球范围内具有潜在灾难性的问题，是一个令人兴奋的挑战。保罗·斯洛维奇是俄勒冈大学的心理学家。要了解更多关于他的工作，请访问erismaticofcompassion.org。保罗，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。不用客气，香卡，这是我的荣幸。最近怎么样？《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。Midrall Media是我们独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的制作团队包括布丽吉特·麦卡锡、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、
Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Ransang hero this week is Michael Kostak Leola. Michael is a composer whose music and sound design work has been featured in theater productions across the country. Since the pandemic has up featured in theater productions across the country. Since the pandemic has upended the theater world, Michael is expanded into making music for podcasts.
奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德维克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是迈克尔·科斯塔克·莱奥拉。迈克尔是一位作曲家，他的音乐和声音设计作品曾在全国各地的戏剧制作中亮相。自从大流行颠覆了戏剧界以来，迈克尔已扩展到为播客创作音乐。
Composing for podcasts is difficult because the music has to be understated to allow the story and ideas to shine. Michael intuitively understands how to do this, and his work has the added benefit of being beautiful and distinctive. You heard some of it in today's episode. Thank you Michael. For more hidden brain you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
为播客作曲很困难，因为音乐必须低调，以便让故事和想法大放异彩。迈克尔直观地理解如何做到这一点，他的作品还有一个额外的好处，那就是优美而独特。你在今天的节目中听到了一些。谢谢你，迈克尔。有关更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果您喜欢这期节目，请务必与朋友分享。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。